all right Brandon
Brandon oh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
from uh Clay County Kentucky drove up in
a town called Old Navy
tell me about your family growing up my
Diane mom uh my dad named Buddy Noble my
mom's name was Cheryl uh Ray Davidson uh
mom was born in Novi my dad was
originally from Wolf County uh
he worked on a farm every day and a mom
she worked at a
school she worked for her own Eddie
Baptist and stood up to the day she died
what she passed away make last year
2021 October 2021 while I was in court
and I had a good mom real good dad
good childhood
uh they won now good childhood yeah good
childhood crazy views nothing like that
no normal childhood preferred you in
school ninth grade ninth grade yeah what
happened I started having trouble with
the police uh they stopped the school
bus searching for drugs when they found
out I'd be on it and
just just one thing or another so you
started with drugs early
start pretty early it's coming down here
right it's about the only thing it was
if you wanted wanted anything you just
put myself
My First Love was meth and I figured if
I was going to do it I was going to do
it right so I learned how to cook it
when I was about 15 and
as I did it's meant to be the main drug
down here
do what now is meth the biggest drug in
yeah Appalachian yeah they struggle
around got the pills the pills were big
for a while they went now pills okay
yeah painkillers yeah I got hooked on
pain pills pretty bad I was hooked on
the roxy 30s I cooked meth I cooked meth
pay for them
and it just one thing led to another and
is that how you were making money yeah
yeah
you've been in jail in prison before I
don't know seven years uh first time
first got caught him a manufacturing
charge when I was 18.
over in Laurel County and a they
couldn't charge manufacturing they
dropped it down the pre-cursors I took
five years on hit
about
18 going on 19.
ended up doing the five
got out on Pro back then there wasn't no
sanctions when you get out you mess up
you come back
well I was out one night and
forgot to go to the parole officer next
thing you know I'm on the run and
I've been up by the weight and I was
going outside out of town to get me some
pills and uh
run into a roadblock and we passed out a
buddy of mine's vehicle and they got me
again with another bag of dope
give me two more of your own hit made a
total of seven
so I went on to prison I was in prison
when I was 19.
how many years you been in prison now
right now I've been locked up again this
time two years I've been out six months
in the last five years I just done a
five for playing invading and uh eight
in their evidence on them they said
and they give me five uh five on hit I
got out October 30th to 2020 had locked
back up April 16th to 2021.
how old are you uh by 38 September this
year so you spent a lot of your life in
yeah it's been a lot of my life in here
your kids yeah got one little boy named
Brandon Earl and where's he he's uh down
here at my brother's house
yeah where's the mother
uh she's waiting yeah
we put him up a trailer back behind my
brother's trailer and he stays down
there
so you're here in Kentucky this is not a
prison this is just a jail
it is just class new jail right now but
I'm waiting to go to prison you're going
to prison yeah they can't classify me
here yeah
you spend a lot of your time in jail or
prison what does it do to you
emotionally bye
it's just I guess just I'm used to it I
guess
get institutionalized
you get institutionalized I believe I am
I mean the days go by faster in here
than anything to do on the street yeah
yeah I mean I miss my family and I miss
the women and stuff I heard it come with
the lifestyle but
I've got to let it go when I get out but
I mean do you get depressed in here
depressed yeah
I mean I got the prayers when my mom
died yeah be your friends here in jail
yeah I got plenty of friends and uh they
want me to say hi to them they wrote
their names down on that piece of paper
and I'm gonna say hi to them on camera
before I leave
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
well
man that's a hard quick
but I'd say if I had it do over
I wouldn't play with mayor and I wanted
13 young into watching this and sees
this I want to know if it may look fun
and you may look like you got everything
Whirled in the palm of your hand and you
will have for a while
it brung it all to me but in the end it
took it all back away from me
you know watch it on a video because I'm
high risk and they couldn't take me to
the Old Navy Community just afraid I'd
get away from them you're high risk
because of the uh
and I've been charged with a lot of
stuff but only some of it stuck I've
been charged Champion murder on police
officers I've been charged with
Flynn invading numerous times
and done time on it
I don't know why they consider me a high
risk I think I'm a good guy
what kind of teenager were you teenage
but that's probably a Hellraiser
yeah
is there peer pressure to do what
everyone else is doing or is this way
you're cut
I had a lot of friends we've done a lot
of flying you know what I'm saying is
Appalachia part of the problem the fact
that there's not a whole lot to do well
they they ain't no jobs here they you
know coal mining has dried up okay oh
man I don't know nothing about no Coal
Mine uh and I figured before I bought it
worked for 230 a day uh I'm gonna do
what I gotta do you know
get by but I had a job ready when I got
locked up this time Gotti caulking I was
going to start on Monday and uh I like I
said I ain't been out six months I don't
have any four or five vehicles bought
and paid for
that's money which is in the evidence I
give them or to look at having some cash
enough cash and stuff put up
you know where I can start work and not
have to worry about nothing
I don't know I got a call to meet
somebody at the parking lot at the store
and drop something off when I got there
man
I dropped it off I went down the road
turned around I come back and they had
two K-9 units and five quarters live
waiting on me you set up I've set up
yeah
I had a female with me when I got caught
but uh they done a background check on
her when she got her to jail and found
out she's a good Christian like lady and
they let her go
I don't know what happened do you have
siblings do you have brothers and
sisters I got a two brothers one sister
and I got a half sister that lives in
North Carolina
or any of your siblings in a similar
kind of trouble
no no they all they all good my sister
she works at doctor's office my brothers
they do Gotti caulking out of Lexington
and uh
uh I don't know what my sister in North
Carolina's doing I ain't seen her in a
long time what do you think it is that
makes you different
buddy at an early age man I was a when I
was 10 11 year old I always hung around
with the older people like you know
wash cars and stuff for a buddy of mine
a well buddy of my dad's he had a car
lot and stuff I'd wash car and stuff for
him he'd drink on weekend play poker and
stuff
I'd live in 12 years old I'd win 12 1300
a weekend playing poker man and uh you
grew up fast grew up fast I was like in
the room with the older guys man they
showed me love and uh
playing poker man and
been like about 13 14. I'm a little
buddies on the holiday light part my
uncles grew pop so I'd help him clean it
and they'd give me what was left
and I like their money so
just the way to go yeah living that life
or you're chasing fast money and getting
in trouble is it adrenaline that becomes
the adrenaline the excitement of it all
they become as addictive yeah yeah and
then eventually you play around with
drugs and you get addicted to the drugs
as well mentally start smoking the meth
and
started doing 30s and
I didn't think there's no end inside you
know I'm just like the next man I heard
I thought there wasn't nobody gonna take
me down
and
other drugs here in jail or in prison
hey yes she drives a powder house in
here really yeah
so you got to withdraw when you're here
well if you're out
I I don't withdraw I never withdraw when
I come in off the street
I knew I couldn't get it you know the
knew I was done before
I know when they bring me through the
door there's a salad for it I know it's
over they won't lower my bond they won't
let me out
I mean I've seen people come in here the
same charges as me seen one boy in here
on murder charge he got seven mirror I
got 12 years for a 45 and 22 grams of
dope and a couple thousand dollars in
money
is that because all your repeat offenses
uh that's what they say I mean your
record just they couldn't they dismissed
the PFO so I don't see why that'd have
anything to do with it
what's your biggest fear now
biggest pure Logan's another one of my
family members while I'm locked up
that's about the only thing up here
what would you like to see happen
you're in here for how long you're in
prison oil beer I go up Pro September I
said you have can you see beyond those
12 years
do you have any goals you just you just
want to yeah yeah I like get out say
straight
stay sober live my life spend the rest
of my life with my young I missed out on
August life
they they born I got locked up at the
hospital for trafficking charges
police come in and bring him up from his
mother had a C-section just bringing him
up
doors bust open please police busting in
on us and
heading that much tracking made that and
so yeah for all the trouble and
excitement that you got into
do you have any good memories of all
that
not at all but I'm getting older and
it's getting hard to remember tonight I
just remember beds and pay stuff
I mean I remember some wrecks from some
high-speed chases I've been on and stuff
like that but other than that now it's
all bad what's the craziest thing you
got into with the police are with
anybody
with the police
let's see
you got an attempted murder and that's
that's uh yeah that was dismissed uh
I'd say buddy I had this woman driving
me one night I won't mention no names
but she's driving me one night we've
been uh been over in London and uh
we stopped that place and a Polish sat
there and we pulled in
I looked at her I told her you better
not stop because you know I was trying
to get rid of my stuff then uh
we got our way from the dollar store by
the Burger King you know where it's at
all the way down to make it to college
for it I had her she had she didn't know
how to drive she's around about 110 and
uh there's a police lived down there
across from the great School in the
stretcher
are saying and uh
I told her I said damn you better hit
the dirt road fast I said because this
guy can drive because I've run him
before and he picked my nose man we
flipped about six times and
I come out of the vehicle running and
there's waiting on me they finally
caught me but they had to fly that woman
out it messed her head up a little bit
but
that's probably about the craziest Chase
I've been on I'll arrest him turned out
pretty good that the canine units got
here does it like to be attacked by a
bunch of police dogs
it ain't fun it ain't fun
they got a place a place out here didn't
find money find your guns find whatever
you throw it's going back and getting it
Brandon what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
most important lesson
definitely
take each day as it comes and
when you walk out the door from your mom
and dad let them know you love them
because it may be the last time you see
them
all right Brandon thank you so much for
sharing your story
no problem I wish you luck once you get
out all right thank you thank you